[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we
returned to the murky swamps of
tick-tock ready to cancel everything in
our path and right away a good candidate
presents itself here's a feminist woman
named christy who looks exactly like
every other feminist woman named christy
that you've ever you've ever met if
you've had the misfortune of meeting
more than one just as a quick
introduction to christy
uh this is not the video we're going to
focus on today but i just want to play
one of her most recent contributions
here she is on the issue of race listen
in honor of this
white people stitch this
how many white people i make it my
personal business
to have complex conversations about race
with any and all white people that i
encounter
complex conversations about race with
all white people that you encounter how
does that work are you stopping people
on the street excuse me sir i'd like to
have a complex conversation about race
with you maybe you go door to door like
a jehovah's witness except significantly
more annoying
i shudder at the thought of being stuck
next to her on an airplane for three
hours
just one more reason to choose a seat in
the exit row i guess
the exit would be for her not for me in
that case anyway that gives you an idea
of where she's uh where she's coming
from now let's get to the main event
i'm here to double down on the video
that made me go viral
most men
are rapists
and by that i mean most cis
heteronormative men there's a reason we
say we live in a rape culture most rapes
go unreported some even unknown and the
way rape is portrayed and glamorized in
movies and media misrepresents what most
rape actually looks like let's just look
at the updated definition of rape so
that everybody's clear penetration no
matter how slight of the vagina or anus
or any other body part or object or oral
penetration by a sex organ of another
person without the consent of the victim
are you buying somebody drinks with the
goal of getting them drunk enough so
that they can't consent
rapist
coercing somebody into sex
rapist
guilting or manipulating someone into
having sex with you
rapist dating coaches and pickup artists
have normalized this kind of behavior
and if you engage in any of those things
you'll be known as a rapist
is your just the tip joke funny now
always with the hair they all have the
same hair do they go to like the hair
salon and say uh yeah i'm a shrill
feminist just so go ahead and do do what
you do
now you notice how she lets gay men off
the hook at the start because apparently
male on male rape doesn't exist this
will come as welcome news to everybody
who's going to prison from there she
gives us a definition of rape that few
could argue with rape is having sex with
someone performing any kind of sexual
act with them
without their consent yeah that's
obviously what the term means but then
she performs the trick that has become
so common in our culture a trick that
has led to lots of confusion and to
very many ruined lives
by manipulating the word consent you'll
notice that she doesn't pull out the old
websters to tell us what the word
consent means she does that with rape
but not consent because if she had we'd
see that consent means agreement to do
something
that's it if you agree to do it you
consent it
if you were forced to do it you didn't
consent so it's that simple
she provides the example of a man it's
always a man as if women don't do this
a man getting a woman drunk in order to
have sex with her now if someone is
trying to intoxicate another person
with the explicit goal of taking
advantage of them and the other person
has no sober intention of engaging in
any kind of sexual activity
then yes that could be a form of
removing consent
but the problem is that in most cases
where alcohol is involved especially
somewhere like a college campus you have
two people in a sexually charged
environment both getting drunk
and then both having sex while drunk
who's the rapist there both of them are
they raping each other
well the school rape tribunals always
put the blame on men in fact i'm not
aware of a single case where a woman has
been charged or even accused of rape
after a mutual drunk sex
the onus always falls on men
from there she makes rape into an even
more obscure concept by claiming that
men again always men because women never
do this
men who guilt manipulate or coerce women
into sex are rapists now
it's possible to imagine forms of
coerced sex that would count as rape if
you tell a woman to have sex with you or
you'll kill her
that's coercion and it's obviously rape
but she says that that most
most straight men are rapists which
means she's talking about far less dire
and more generalized versions of
manipulation
essentially what feminists mean when
they say this is that trying to convince
a woman to have sex
using any form of persuasion at all
is rape
which is another way of saying that a
man who tries to initiate sex
even with his own wife potentially
is a rapist
you would have to mean that if you're
trying to support the claim that most
men are rapists which is obviously
ludicrous
and worse than ludicrous as this
mentality has again ruined the lives of
many men by providing women with the
framework to accuse their consensual
sexual partners of rape after the fact
the word consent
means what it means in reality if you
agree to do it
if you're not
forced but you agreed
then you've consented
even if you did it but you didn't want
to
even if you did it and you felt bad
about it later
even if you did it but only because you
thought it was the only way to secure
promotion at work in all of those cases
in any case like them
you have agreed you have participated of
your own free will and volition you were
not raped but even if you weren't raped
does that mean that you weren't used
is it possible for someone to be
sexually used
and yet not raped yes in fact it's
possible and it happens all the time and
it's bad but it's not rape at the end of
the video she says via text on the
screen there that feeling entitled to
someone's body for sexual pleasure is a
rapist mentality
now it isn't necessarily
but it is a perverse and degraded
mentality
it's also the mentality that many people
in our culture men and women share
the moment that we ripped the sexual act
out of the loving and committed confines
of marriage we turned it into a purely
selfish act performed by individuals for
their own gratification
everyone involved in hookup culture is
using someone's body for sexual pleasure
everyone who looks at porn is doing that
um
most of the people men and women on
dating apps are pursuing exactly that
are they all rapists no i mean some of
them are by by statistics would seem to
indicate but but most of them aren't
the problem as i've described in the
past is that in our culture today
we have no moral language to govern sex
except consent that's the only moral
guide that we have left because we've
thrown everything else out
the idea that sex used to be loving used
to be
sex is supposed to be loving and
supposed to be committed
all of that we've thrown out
and we've left only consent
as the one single moral rule left to
govern the sexual act
and a lot of people like the person in
the video there
have without realizing it notice the
problem
they may live they've looked around and
they've seen that wow i mean gee
so often
sex in our culture today is it's
degraded
it seems immoral amoral
people are just using each other as
objects
i mean to to use someone else simply as
basically a glorified masturbatory aid
as just this tool for you to
get your thrills
that's a terrible thing it's
dehumanizing
and and it is
but because they're committed to this
idea
that we all need to be libertines
that we can't you know that the the
concept that sex is supposed to be
loving and committed that's patriarchal
that's religious
if they're committed to that
so they've thrown that out
all they have left is consent
and so they decide that oh okay well all
these cases here these are all
violations of consent
and that's how i'm going to be able to
condemn them
they're not
but in many cases they are still immoral
and that's why today
even though even though she she like so
many feminists on this issue
there may be there may be closer to the
to the point they're closer to the truth
than they realize
[Music]
still i have to say that today she is
canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated